bonsoir merci de répondre à nos
questions vous avez évidemment suivi
cette cérémonie d'investiture
particulière qu'est ce que vous retenez
d'abord le dispositif militaire
impressionnant et l'absence de foule
on voit bien toutes les conséquences de
de l'absence de la du 6 janvier regarder
les images c'est c'est totalement vide
il ya on n'a jamais vu une cérémonie
pareil sans public en fait elle est
faite pour la télévision et pour lui et
pour lui pour les archives
est-ce que j'ai une cérémonie qui va
rester dans les annales sans donald
trump inquiets du côté de la floride
dans quel état d'esprit là sûrement vous
il est vous êtes alors qu'il allait se
battre je crois que c'est possible
puisque aux dernières nouvelles il songe
à créer un son propre parti politique
qu'il appellerait on verra bien s'il le
fait qu'il appellerait le parti patriote
se serait pas tellement étonnant puisque
vous avez vu que mcconnell a
effectivement officiellement imputée à
trump la responsabilité de l'émeute du 6
janvier
est ce qu'il y aura assez de sénateurs
républicains pour voter une censure ça
j'en suis moins sûr mais effectivement
maintenant le pas le parti républicain
est très divisé et trump certainement
songe à créer son propre mouvement et
environ 30 % seulement des américains à
ce moment qu'ils pensent qu'il pourrait
encore faire de nouveaux qui a un
président est intéressant pour un
deuxième mandat
mais c'est pas du est pas du genre à se
laisser apparaître sa session devait
prêter serment tout à l'heure aux
alentours de 18h heure française et
quelles vont être les premiers
sujet les premiers dossiers qu'il devra
faire je vous propose de l'écouter
nous sommes une grande nation mon peuple
et malgré la guerre malgré la malgré le
conflit
nous avons tant progressé il nous reste
tant à faire
nous allons avancer avec beaucoup de
vitesse car il ya beaucoup de choses à
faire
il ya beaucoup de possibles et beaucoup
de choses à réparer ont restauré à
guérir a construit à vue a gagné
beaucoup de choses à faire selon vous
laurent césar et ça veut dire quoi
beaucoup de choses à faire c'est quoi
quels sont les premiers dossiers
prioritaires de joe biden le dossier
prioritaire ça sera très certainement de
la lutte contre l'épidémie de 2cv 19
c'est vraiment ce qu'est le la priorité
du moment et je pense que c'est ça qui
va et ce à quoi il va se différencier
d'ailleurs tout de suite pas de ça sera
le moyen le plus simple de se
différencier de son prédécesseur de
trump qui avait été celle axe east en
affaires et jeu et donc ça va être très
certainement des mesures de court terme
qui vont tomber extrêmement vite
certainement pour accélérer pour
accélérer les vaccinations pour faire en
sorte que le col port du masque
deviennent davantage imposés c'était la
toute première chose ensuite vous aurez
certainement des mesures de relance
économique puisque le avec donc en
particulier le lait 2000 dollars
d'indemnités qu'il a fallu forcer un
petit peu la main à baden pour pour qui
les acceptent kivu qui vont être lancées
aussi je pense que sur ces mesures
il va faire quelque chose parce qu'il
est très fortement sous la surveillance
de la gauche du du parti républicain
dans les bureaux du parti démocrate
s'est excusé excusez moi et sanders état
et le président de la
mission du budget ce qui lui permet dans
certains cas de faire passer des mesures
sans atteindre une majorité des deux
tiers dont on peut s'attendre et stocker
effectivement un plan de relance assez
important qui à moyen terme porterait
notamment sur le développement des
infrastructures routières ou autres qui
sont souvent dégradés pour ce qui est du
soutien aux entreprises ça sera assez
différent de tram ça sera un petit peu
avec murat côté aides à l'innovation
plutôt que plutôt que comme des laissés
en de laisser ans en activité des
entreprises déclinante
il y aura certes hélas politique
concernant les relocalisations seront
sera certainement poursuivi en forme on
peut penser qu'il y aura des primes pour
les entreprises qui accepteraient de
relocaliser aux états unis beaucoup de
chantiers on l'a compris pour pour john
madden à venir et le premier vous
l'évoquez tout à l'heure laurent cesari
c'est évidemment à l'épidémie de
coronavirus je vous propose d'écouter
justement jabbari donne à ce sujet c'est
un virus c'est le virus du siècle il a
emporté tandis que les etats-unis en ont
perdu toute la seconde guerre mondiale
des millions d'emplois ont disparu
des centaines de milliers de commerces
ont fermé la justice raciale l'égalité
pour tous plus être repoussée
voilà donc les mots de joe biden lors de
son discours
d'investiture sur l'épidémie de
coronavirus on sait que que cette
pandémie a été un sujet un tout au long
de la campagne électorale entre donald
trump et joe biden divisés sur le sujet
laurent cesari oui absolument c'est
vraiment deux deux options complètement
différente et il est fort probable que
c'est une d une des raisons qui ont fait
perdre qui ont fait perdre trump savent
beaucoup affaibli dans l'électorat des
personnes âgées en particulier qui était
ok auparavant lui était acquis et ça l'a
empêché aussi de prendre de certaines
boucheries côté sur la relance
économique et sur le fait que la reine
avec des colonies a pas été mauvaises
durant son mandat pour se faire réélire
là évidemment ça s'est fracassée très
nettement the maiden qui s'est exprimé
également au sujet de l'unité je propose
de l'écouter et puis vous pourrez réagir
ensuite laurent césar y soutient pas
votre confiance à ceux qui n'ont pas
soutenu étudier et si nous sommes
toujours pas d'accord très bien ça la
démocratie c'est ça les états unis le
jeu facebook
nous avons le droit d'être en désaccord
pacifique c'est peut-être la plus grande
part de son intention désaccord ne pas
mener à l'adhésion et je vous en fais je
serai le président de tous les
américains
comment joe biden pourrait être le
président de tous les américains quand
on sait qu'il ya 74 millions
d'américains qui ont voté pour donald
trump quand on sait également
qu'il ya eu les incidents du 6 janvier
du côté du capitole est également les
divers manifestations blacklight matters
ces derniers temps c'est un vaste
chantier
je pense qu'effectivement ça va pas être
facile
c'est la rhétorique évidemment attendu
de tous président qui commence qui
commence son mandat et je crois qu'il va
y avoir des difficultés
ça correspond certainement ou ou vu le
profond 2 bat edel qui a toujours tenté
d'avoir des milliers des majorités
bipartisanes tas de grappiller de
chercher les lecteurs les électeurs
centristes dents dans le parti d'en face
mais justement les républicains ne sont
pas sur cette voie alors peut-être
justement que les choses lui seront
facilitées par le fait qu' une partie du
parti les membres du parti républicain
commence à s'éloigner de la trup est ici
il s'en éloigne pour des raisons assez
simple c'est que beaucoup de grandes
sociétés qui finançait les campagnes
électorales
les républicains sont depuis le 6
janvier beaucoup plus réticente et font
savoir que pour tous ceux par exemple
qui comptent qui aurait contesté les
résultats de l'élection présidentielle
le 2020 n'y aurait plus dur et peu de
financements occultes possible que l'ale
standard pro-business habituel sens plus
du parti républicain revienne à une
opposition standard l os x est pas
absolument garanti et d'autre part il
faudra également que vahid est négocié
ou sein de son propre parti démocrate où
il ya effective où il ya une aile gauche
qui a beaucoup qui s'est beaucoup démené
pour le pour le faire élire
malgré le mal gré le donc l'élimination
qu'elle était vraiment programmé par la
direction du parti de sanders ils ont
ils n'ont pas été en cuisine mais
maintenant certainement ils vont
demander des comptes
or il faudra compter avec les démocrates
conservateurs car il y en a aussi
donc la rhétorique
la rhétorique comment dire de l'union et
va pour l'instant j'y vois j voi
rhétorique laurent césar et comment est
ce que vous qualifieriez en un mot cette
cérémonie d'investiture si particulière
comme l'a évoqué à l'instant at home
abonné depuis washington
il ya une volonté très laide de retour à
la normale c'est ça que qui est évident
tout les tout le cérémonial habituel est
respecté à la lettre
sauf qu'à personnes vous avez 190
drapeau pour remplacer la foule
les formules sont suivis à la lettre
il ya une volonté très nette vous avez
également tout le discours de ben laden
qui disent ah non ça ne se répètera plus
jamais on voit très nettement une
volonté de tirer un trait sur le passé
il ya des actes également de joe biden
avec la signature de décrets pour
tourner la page
donald trump dix sept décrets qui vont
être signés propose vous propose de
regarder les mesures phares qui vont
être prises par par joe biden le 7
juillet dernier le président donald
trump a retiré les états unis de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé oms
qui l'accusé d'avoir mal géré la
pandémie de coronavirus l'immunologue
anthony fochi va intervenir comme
représentant des états unis à une
réunion du conseil exécutif de l'om sd
ce jeudi le démocrate qui a fait de la
lutte contre le changement climatique
une autre priorité de son mandat
adressera dès ce mercredi un courrier à
l'onu afin que les etats unis puissent
réintégrer la corde paris d'ici un mois
les etats unis s'étaient retirés de cet
accord seulement quelques mois après
l'investiture de donald trump joe biden
va signé une proclamation pour arrêter
la construction d'un mur à la frontière
avec le mexique engagé par donald trump
et son finances
par ailleurs il va annuler un décret
migratoire controversée adoptée par son
prédécesseur pour interdire aux
ressortissants de pays en majorité
musulman d'entrée aux états unis joe
biden va signer un décret pour ordonner
aux agences fédérales d'évaluer les
inégalités raciales dans leurs
programmes comme leur politique et pour
réinstaurer les formations à la
diversité supprimées par son
prédécesseur
au total c'est donc une quinzaine de
décret 17 exactement qu'est ce que ça
vous inspire laurence et harry il ya
d'une part l'arrêt dont vous avez parlé
des mesures qui étaient les plus
provocantes je pense particulièrement
aux murs de que de surcroît trump eux
voulaient contrôler voulais qu'il soit
financé par le mexique il ya l'art est
aussi de vos données d'idées des mesures
contre l'immigration musulmane tout ça
et le ski est extrêmement significatif
c'est l'abominable retour à l'om s et la
nomination de fausi halloweenesque et le
flic est d abord la bête noire de trump
puisque il contredisait de l'intérieur
ce que disait le président / / / la clcv
19 et il ya effectivement les premières
mesures qui sont prises par décret sont
vraiment un retour une négation 2d
justement à propos de ces décrets ray
notamment la corse en climat de paris je
vous permets je me permets de vous je
vous aurais parce qu'il ya une
déclaration d' emmanuel macron à
l'instant à à joe biden le site welcome
back dans l'accord de paris sur le
climat oui je dois répondre où je suis
symbolique l'équipe dont je sais vous
allez me montrer macro excusez moi c'est
symboliquement c'est une très bonne
chose
ça montre une volonté d'engagement ce
qui permettra éventuellement aussi la
suite de conversations avec la chine
dans les faits c'est peut-être moins
significatif car l'absence de l'état
américain dans dans l'accord sur le
climat n'a pas empêché des actions au
niveau des états fédérés ou d où d où de
grandes municipalités qui fera d'elle
même des mesures pour comme pour limiter
les émissions de ges mais en tout cas
évidemment cet été c'est à la fois
symbolique et est attendu attendu
également le départ de donald trump qui
a quitté la maison blanche vers 14h tout
à leur heure française un départ à bord
d'un hélicoptère pour survoler le
capitole comme un symbole et pour se
rendre ensuite sur la base militaire
d'andrews situé dans la bas dans la
banlieue de washington
la dernière cérémonie et ultime discours
donc avant de s'envoler à bord d'air
force one pour la floride où il a
atterri un peu avant l'investiture de
kamala harris et de joe biden donald
trump qui affirment vouloir revenir je
me battrai toujours pour vous je
regarderai j'écouterai et je vous dirais
que le futur de ce pays n'a jamais été
aussi bon je souhaite à la nouvelle
administration beaucoup de chance
beaucoup de succès je pense qu'elle aura
beaucoup de succès elle a de bonnes
fondations pour faire des choses
vraiment spectaculaire et je le redis
nous l'avons mise dans des conditions
telles que ça n'a jamais été fait
auparavant et ce malgré la pire pandémie
qui nous est frappé depuis je suppose
en dépit de cela ce que nous avons fait
a été incroyable et nous n'aurions pas
pu le faire sans vous donc c'est juste
un au revoir je vous aime je reviendrai
d'une manière ou d'une autre
je reviendrai d'une manière ou d'une
autre donc c'est 2024 qu'il a en point
de mire laurence hézard et vous parliez
tout à l'heure de donald trump pour
vouloir créer un nouveau parti
dans les prochains jours qu'est ce qui
va se passer pour donald trump
ah bin là ça dépend de ce qui va se
passer au bout c'est là est ce qu'il va
être condamné ou non parce que il faut
qu'il faut qu'ils disent est sénateur
républicain qui vote qui le condamne le
khimki pour le pour les bouquets du
monde ça c'est pas garantie du tout mais
en revanche si ensuite il est
effectivement condamné de trouver une
majorité de 51 pour l'empêcher de se
représenter sa sera extrêmement facile
là on est le sort de trump en fait et
politique est suspendu au vote du sénat
et personnellement je sais pas s'il y
aura dix sept sénateurs républicains qui
iront jusqu'à le jusqu'à jusqu'à voter
contre lui l'information avait une
alerte qui vient de tomber au sujet de
l'administration trump des responsables
de l'administration tron dont my pompéo
l'ancien secrétaire d'état
visées par des sanctions de la part de
pékin pékin qui annonce des sanctions
donc contre l'ancien chef de la
diplomatie sous donald trump et des
responsables de l'administration trump
ça vous évoque quoi je pense que c'est
une réponse du berger à la bergère
puisque le dernier acte de pompes et ça
a été de déclarer que le traitement des
ouigours par la chine c'est ce qu'a dit
hier est un génocide
or c'est un terme qui va loin au delà de
la condamnation morale puisque la
convention internationale pour la
prévention des génocides prévoit à
l'article 1 que tous les états doivent
coopérer pour prévenir le génocide donc
c'est un appel franc et massif à la
comau dire à une politique anti
chinoises dur c'est évidemment un
comment dire une pierre dans le jardin
de byden qui ne sera pas comme dire
qu'il va continuer certainement une
politique assez ferme envers la chine
mais enfin je pense pas qu'il aurait
voulu aller jusque là ça dit quels sont
exactement ces rétorsion chinoise contre
popeo là j'avoue que je n'ai pas
d'informations on voit sur ces images
l'une des dernières images de donald
trump en tant que président des états
unis c'est s était tout à l'heure du
côté de la base
d'andrews du côté de washington pour
pour terminer cette édition spéciale
consacrée à cette investiture de joe
biden à ce départ de donald trump
qu'est ce que vous diriez ou finale
laurent césar et surtt remous sur deviez
si vous deviez qualifié cette journée si
particulière
je pense que c'est très nettement une
tentative de la part de tout le monde
de retour à la normale je les dis pour
byden je le dis également pour trump
puisque vous avez vous l'avez montré en
train de souhaiter bonne chance à
comment dire à la fois son successeur
alors même qu'il n'a pas voulu assister
à son à son investiture ce qui est dans
une certaine mesure mais jean limite est
bien entendu une volonté de respecter
les formes habituelles
et bien c'est le monde de l'enfant merci
laurence hézard et d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
professeur d'histoire contemporaine à
l'université d'arras socialiste
évidemment des états unis